one day after receiving advice from
australia's solicitor general prime
minister anthony albanese unveiled his
report
it's found that his predecessor's
decision to appoint himself covertly to
five ministerial roles was legal but
failing to inform his cabinet the
parliament the public and for ministers
was inconsistent with how the country
should be run
the advice so
is i think a very clear
clear
criticism
and critique
of the implications that are there for
our democratic system of government
during the pandemic scott morrison swore
himself in as joint minister for health
home affairs finance treasury and
resources
the governor general oversaw the
appointment but he too didn't inform
parliament that was cleared by the
nation's top lawyer albanese says a
wider inquiry is needed
the inquiry will need to examine what
happened and how it happened
it will also need to examine what the
implications are
for what occurred
over whether there are any uh legal
issues that are raised
constitutional lawyers agree and say
that parliament needs to be informed of
all ministerial appointments if
democracy is to be upheld if we have
secret ministers as it seems we had uh
that's an affront to those principles
and to those norms that
frustrates uh the ability and prevents
parliament holding ministers accountable
if you don't know who the ministers are
and which ministers are responsible for
what uh parliament can't that process of
ministerial accountability department
doesn't work prime minister albanese has
flagged the loophole that allows
ministry appointments to be made without
informing the public and has asked his
department to make that a priority
as for scott morrison the former prime
minister said it was in the national
interest for him to take on the extra
portfolios during the pandemic an
extraordinary and unprecedented time
so far he's refused to resign sarah
clark al jazeera brisbane australia